today we have breaking news coming out
of thailand thailand has gone ahead and
made the decision that they are going to
ban bitcoin and cryptocurrencies as a
form of payment now there's some nuance
in this decision to actually ban bitcoin
and crypto as a form of payment that's
important to actually pay attention to
first it is not a complete ban their
version of the sec is stressing that the
ban is on crypto payments not on trading
or digital assets in general this is
important because as more and more
people begin to adopt these assets some
of them are doing it from an investment
standpoint some of them are using it as
a savings technology and others are
trying to use it as a means of payment
and so thailand is specifically
targeting the use as a payment system
they think that there is not an
improvement from a technology standpoint
we have a quote from the thailand sec in
which they state digital assets do not
provide improved efficiency to the
payments market because of their
volatility and high transaction fees
while that may be the position of this
regulatory body in thailand i happen to
disagree what we know is that there's
almost 200 billion dollars in stable
coins globally people are using those
stable coins not just because they have
stable value but because the payment
rails on which they are used are
superior to the legacy system on top of
that there are millions and millions and
millions of people around the world that
use bitcoin as a payment method as well
those people understand that things like
the lightning network allow you to send
any amount of economic value whether
it's one penny or a million dollars
instantaneously completely for free with
final cash settlement that is also
superior to any other payment method in
the legacy world my guess is that the
people of thailand will continue to
adopt bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
they'll use it as an investment vehicle
they'll use it as a savings technology
and they'll likely continue to use it as
a payment technology as well eventually
i think that the regulators are going to
understand that they're making a misstep
they'll come around and they'll go ahead
and actually encourage people not only
to invest not only to saving these
technologies but also use it as a medium
of exchange as well hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time